OPPORTUNITY. 3- HUNT AND
THEN STROME BACK TO THEY.
CUT
TO THE MINNESOTA ZONE.
>> I GOAL.
AND KAPRIZOV
♪ ♪
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SETTING THE ZO.
>> MIKA STORY. BYMATTER THAT GUG
AROUND AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
AFTER LINDGREN.
NICO STRUM TRYING TO TAKE IT
THIS ONE CERTAINLY NOT ON HIM.
PERFECT EXECUTION, JONAS BRODINN
OUTSTANDING.
SCORES. TIED UP CAPITALIZE.
HERE A LITTLE BIT OF PRESSURE
FO BRODIN.
MATT BOLDY RANGERS VERY AGGRESS,
THEY STAY IN THE BATAT HOME CRO,
INCLUDED WILD HAVE A FACE-OFF IE
NEUTRAL ZONE.
HE TRIES TO GET LOST.
A NICE GREAT JOB WITH
ONE TOUCH BEFORE THEY CAN CATCH
UP WITHHE
OUT.
HUNT CARRIES IT BACKEAGUE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NAMES OFEDT
AS THEY ARE COMING OFF PAST
STICK TOWARD THE HAS IT FOR